if it's canceled the Toolman as
everything exhale yes yeah yeah just
just had enough have been on the road or
yeah a long stretch roughly more than
150 shows across six continents for 18
months
Justin's purchase world tour is shutting
down earlier than expected with sources
saying the singer is super exhausting
and that the lengthy tour was taking a
toll on doing stadiums in the United
States he's starting a stadium tour
Justin announced on Ellen back in
December that he'd be adding extra dates
and just last week his team booked an
all-star opening act lineup including
Nick Menza kailani and migos but now
those final 14 stadiums will be
purposeless any message for family
I love you Matt sorry for explaining who
feels like disappointed - betrayed - my
now Justin's manager Scooter Braun is
also apologizing hosting this photo on
Instagram saying on behalf of myself
Justin and the team we are sorry that
was never our intent but a man's soul
and well-being I truly care about came
first and we must all respect and honor
that then scooter adds in the PostScript
now please stop commenting on all my
other photos that have nothing to do
with this yep
when a star of Justin's magnitude shuts
down a tour safe to say it will get some
backlash fans are firing their
frustrations off on social media but one
person coming to Justin's defense John
Mayer the singer tweets when someone
pulls remaining dates of a tour it means
they would have done real damage to
themselves if they kept going we've lost
so many great artists lately
I give Justin two thumbs up for
realizing it was time to call it you
should too
yesterday Justin spent his first
official day off hiking with a model
named Audriana Michelle and grabbing
some goods at a 7-eleven looks like he's
already enjoying his RNR looking forward
to some downtime extracting
relaxation tried to fight not